I'm his team oh I miss him our flight
just got delayed we are delayed again
that's it what's the blue nation happy
weekend it is time for our annual March
Break trip and we were taking you guys
along the ride with us
[Music]
so every year we go lunch break we take
Hayden we go on a trip every year we
basically gone to Disney and we've done
a lot of fun things and Disney I like
having the joke where we're at the
Mexico Pavillion and that's where I met
Nina and I'm very sad that I don't get
to do that this year haven't I seen you
here before
it's a very special place for us we met
you Oh who's this hello hmm
what's your name
this year though Hayden does not want to
go to Disney he wants to go on a cruise
so we are hopping a cruise with
celebrity to Mexico the real Mexico so I
could I could pretend like I met Nina in
actual Mexico I feel like the traditions
gone a little bit I'm a little bit sad
about this but we get lots of amazing
food and I'm very pumped about that so
we are leaving tomorrow morning it is
now what eight o'clock 8:30 I have
impact oh did you pack for me no no so I
need to pack I think it's my last
responsibility I've been working on
videos launching Spanish channels hit my
insta game yeah that's true we're gonna
go on a promotion tour for my Mexican
channel Spanish channel with 20
subscribers
yeah starting from the bottom Teemo is
gonna be stained with J your eyes Teemo
your eyes in the house Teemo is gonna be
very sad yeah Nina's gonna be even
sadder I guaranteed me as Teemo blues
will kick in I'm thinking like four and
a half hours into the trip I miss chemo
I wonder if Justin will send me a
picture too I don't want to ask no one
asked about one of those Sonia pictures
I did where is it anyway so I'm going to
pack up and then we're gonna get the bed
and I'm gonna wake up and hey
- so this is my backpack all of my
clothes all of my gear all of my laptop
everything has to fit in that I do not
believe in luggage or carry-ons just one
backpack
hashtag backpack forever time to fill it
with clothes it's 11 o'clock
just past where I'll packed pretty much
ready to go and have to wake up in five
hours of 45 minutes vacation here we
come 401 a.m. we made it
taking kima out he's not quite sure
what's happening he's not used to being
up this early but we're gonna go out and
then get ready to go
see you J last words of wisdom to leave
us on yea they are words and ride I'll
oh that's it I love it
get by tima we'll see you in a week
we'll see you in a week
Hayden wakes up this morning I'm waking
up wake wake wake up wake up him yes so
excited to go Nina's cousins who are
joining us on the trip was gonna be six
adults five kids they are already at the
airport so we need to hustle our way
[Music]
[Music]
receipts coming out let's see if Nina
gets an X no X Nina no excess time Nina
Nina's clean okay next no accident it is
clean I guess we're all good then we
made it to the United States part of the
China terminal then we get to go on our
plane
time to relax time to get some food we
were at this very terminal on New Year's
Eve getting ready to go to Dallas and
Nina saw the dog die and then we got
turned back this time we're gonna make
it this time we're gonna make it because
we have Hayden last time that flight got
canceled is that gonna happen this time
no how do you know because what is your
car wreck oh nice well I'm a car Michael
to it I got hints about me but not this
time cuz I'm a kid
[Music]
welcome there guys a maple doughnut
like caramel Cheers
[Music]
our flight just got delayed we got
delayed by an hour what's gonna happen
Nina are we gonna make it hate it yes
for sure
no no go back home I feel like this ship
is gonna happen
[Music]
we just got delayed again eight o'clock
one more hour
eight o'clock what do you think what's
gonna happen
hashtag traveling with Nina Hayden's
doing some video production he's making
his own moveable to see your movie
Hayden not yet well we we got delayed
another 20 minutes again Nina oh my god
you're gonna get there Nina Nina it's
not happy yeah let's see your happy
travel face that's your happy couple
let's see your happy type of face I get
to see you angry travel face it's not
very angry
[Laughter]
the plane has arrived because the plane
has arrived what did you get oh she got
boosted you we are delayed again 8:30
not that bad Hayden's getting b-roll for
his video getting some footage let's see
whoa that's crazy if I wanted to feel
like I was falling off a building or
something that's what I would watch I
like it Hayden the video creator okay
director Hayden Carmichael I like it I
like it
producer Evan Carmichael yes
editor Nina Carmichael Oh her name it
has lowercase C that's it what's your
message the messages enjoy your weekend
time to line up the plight lining up I
think we're actually gonna get on this
plane guys there's our plane it arrived
there's a happening at going on vacation
all right let's go hey guys welcome back
to my channel I am here with Archie my
cousin and it is time to go on vacations